Hoy en la media inglesa nos vamos atrás en el tiempo y nos ponemos de gala porque os
vamos a decir cuál es la camiseta más bonita de la historia de cada uno de los 20 clubes
que forman la Premier League.
Un momento, un momento, antes de que arranque el vídeo, dejadme contaros que se acerca
un nuevo viaje de la media inglesa.
Al fin de semana, el 18 y 19 de octubre viajamos a Inglaterra para vivir en directo a un nuevo
partido del Harvard Town como hicimos la temporada pasada.
Solo 289 euros, que incluye todo el fin de semana.
El viernes saldremos desde Londres en autobús hacia Leicester.
Esa noche ya estaremos ahí en Leicester tomando unas cervecillas.
Sábado haremos un tour por Leicester por la mañana, nos iremos a Harvard para ver el
partido y vivir el tercer tiempo con los muchachos.
Por la noche, los que hayan venido a otros viajes ya saben lo que les espera.
Y domingo regreso a Londres.
¿Qué incluyen esos 289 euros?
Lo que no incluyen son los vuelos, pero sí que incluyen todos los traslados en autobús,
dos noches de hotel, desayuno y por supuesto la entrada al partido.
Con el enlace que tenéis aquí abajo podéis comprar ya vuestro viaje para acompañarnos
para ir juntos con toda la comunidad de la media inglesa a vivir este partido el sábado
18 de octubre.
Os esperamos.
Estoy algo afónico, Andrés, porque venimos de grabar un vídeo para miembros jugando al
ping pong y yo las cosas no me las tomo a medias, me las tomo muy en serio.
Mucho gritito, ¿no?
Mucho alarido.
Mucho alarido, mucho lirili, mucho lerele.
Es más lerele que lirili, posiblemente.
Mucho lorolo y muy poco ping pong.
Vale.
Esto también es importante destacarlo, se ríe uno de los causantes de que le haces
eso.
¿Qué tal se te ha dado el asunto?
No diré nada.
Vale.
No diré nada, pero sí diré que quien lleve tiempo viendo el desempeño en la media inglesa
de cualquier cosa que implique un juego competitivo sabrá cómo se me ha dado.
Vale, bueno, me parece más que suficiente.
¿Crees que vamos a tener consenso en las camisetas que vamos a ver hoy?
No lo sé, no lo sé, la verdad.
Yo creo que hay alguna que no te va a acabar de gustar.
Alguna no va a caer bien, ¿no?
En mi…
En ti y posiblemente tampoco en la comunidad.
Quiero mandar un aviso, ¿vale?
Posiblemente…
Lo has hecho tú, el ranking es tuyo.
El ranking es mío.
Puede que aquellos a los que no os gustan los cuellos de polo…
Adiós, la luz.
Son todo cuellos de polo.
Tiene que irse a un momento por sobre estímulos de cuellos de polo.
Pero no es mi culpa, Nacho, que entre 1985 y 2005 una de cada dos camisetas de los clubes
llevaba cuellos de polo.
Bueno, tranquilo, que quedan tres personas viendo el vídeo.
No es mi culpa.
El resto ya es en el rostro.
Bueno, empezamos con una que no tiene cuellos de polo, si te parece, Nacho.
Con orden alfabético, que es el Arsenal.
Y aquí podía haber escogido la mítica de la diosa Haybury, pero aunque no es una camiseta
preciosa como tal, a mí me parece la mejor camiseta de Arsenal en toda su historia,
la Bruce Banana, llevada entre el 91 y el 93.
No acepto un no por respuesta, porque es una camiseta que nunca ha tenido nada ni parecido.
De hecho, los rumores indican, según Foot y Headlines, que en la próxima temporada
va a haber una inspirada en la Bruce Banana.
¿Has visto los intentos de acercamiento de Foot y Headlines a la camiseta?
Sí, sí.
Son las dos horribles.
Sí, lo bueno.
Como no hagan una cosa muy parecida a esta, pues no será horrible.
A ver, entiendo a la gente que diga que es horrorosa.
Hay camisetas que es que hay que entender que hay una compatibilidad entre ser horrorosa
y ser preciosa.
Este es el ejemplo.
Sí, y es icónica.
Es una camiseta, además, ahora que se lleva esto de llevar camisetas retro como ropa de
vestir y tal, es una camiseta muy llevable como ropa de vestir.
Hombre, llevable no lo veo.
Sí, es muy llevable.
El logo de adidas antiguo, la publicidad que no molesta, el logo también, el escudo antiguo
del Arsenal.
Llevable, llevable no es la palabra.
Me parece llevable.
Pero es icónica, es icónica.
Puedo entenderlo.
Lo que pasa es que el Arsenal ha tenido camisetas muy bonitas a lo largo de su historia.
Yo no soy tan fan como todo el mundo de la de la de la homenaje a Haybury porque me parece
bonita pero creo que gana con toda la equipación y con la mística que tenía esa temporada.
Pero la camiseta como tal no es necesariamente la más bonita de la historia del Arsenal.
Me gusta aquella del rayo azul, alguna de rojo y blanco, yo incluso la pondría a lo
mejor por encima de aquella granate, pero estoy contento con esta decisión.
Muy bien.
Vamos a la siguiente que es el Aston Villa, una camiseta también muy mítica, local,
también de los años 90, va a haber muchos años 90.
Lo siento, es la época dorada de las camisetas de fútbol con la camiseta local que llevaron
entre el 90 y el 92, una muy mítica con mita copiers, esos triangulitos de fondo, los patrones
alocados en las mangas y evidentemente el primer cuello de polo del vídeo que no el último.
Muy bien, muy bien, me encanta esta camiseta, además de humbro que siempre ya sabéis que
me ha gustado mucho, esta todavía hoy se sigue viendo, creo que hecho Pablo la tiene.
Es que JD, bueno, Scordro vendió a través de JD Sports unas...
Le quitan humbro.
Sí, y pone el Scordro y ya está.
Y tira para adelante.
Muy bonita esta camiseta.
Y me gusta el detalle del cuello, de los diferentes colores ahí al fondo del cuello.
Sí, ese borde en el cuello muy chulo, los detalles de las mangas, los colores además
respetando la identidad cromática de la Aston Villa, lo tiene todo esta camiseta.
Lo tiene todo y es muy bonita.
Vamos a una visitante que puede ser muy llamativa y que fue reeditada hace poco, que es la del
Borwood, visitante entre el 96 y el 98, mitad amarilla, mitad azul marino barra negro.
Camiseta, puede ser polémica.
Sí, lo es, lo es.
A mí me gusta mucho, me gusta mucho.
A ti no, ¿no?
Jesús, ¿qué opinas?
Es horrible.
A mí, a mí no me gusta, no te voy a engañar.
No me gusta el cuello, no me gusta, ese cuello a medio camino entre el cuello de polo, una
especie de cuello de pico cerrado, no me gusta cómo queda en esta camiseta, no me
gusta el contraste de los bordes rojos de la publicidad y del escudo.
Es lo único malo que tiene.
Con el amarillo y con el azul, no me gusta.
A mí me gusta.
No me gusta.
A mí me gusta y además...
Creo que habría elegido alguna roja y negra del Borwood.
Puede ser, estaba entre una roja y negra del 2001 o 2002 o algo así y esta, pero esta
me ha parecido original y diferente y he querido resaltar.
A Bucheo para Andrés.
A Bucheo, bueno, no pasa absolutamente nada, que no tengáis buen gusto, no es mi problema.
Vamos a otra visitante, esta del Brenfor.
Hace poco hicieron una reedición que la petó.
Evidentemente las locales suelen tirar más porque son los colores habituales del club,
pero esta me parece muy chula, que es la que llevaron entre el 92 y el 94, visitante el
equipo de Londres con KLM como publicidad y de la aerolínea neerlandesa, Hummel, el
escudo retro del Brenfor que creo que le da un toque muy guapo.
Y que es mucho más bonito que el que tuvieron hace unos años.
Y que es mucho más bonito, bueno, es que aquello era...
Qué cosa más fecha que un peito.
Un despropósito, además.
Muy bien esta camiseta.
A mí esta me gusta mucho, me gusta mucho.
Me parece original, con su toque justo de ser cantosa, al mismo tiempo es diferente
y en este caso, por ejemplo, hay un contraste del color con el del escudo, pero no me salta
tanto como la del Borwood.
Cuello abotonado que siempre lo agradecemos.
Por supuesto, es el éxito absoluto.
Es el éxito absoluto.
Me gusta como a toda, hasta la publicidad va muy bien.
Jesús, ¿te gusta más?
Sí.
Vale, bueno, pues mira.
Parece una foto de un edificio.
Hay que decir que hicieron una reedición, no para jugar, sino para vender en el 2022,
una cosa así.
Y, claro, sin el huevo de Hummel.
Porque evidentemente, para poder sacar dinero tienes que quitarlo de alguna forma.
No puedo con esas reediciones.
Uf, a mí me cuestan.
A mí me cuestan.
Un respeto, por supuesto, que se vendan y que la gente las compre con alegría.
Pero si no llevan la marquita de la época es que no estoy viendo la camiseta.
Por ejemplo, una reedición.
Si Hummel ahora decide hacer una reedición de esa camiseta, aunque sea contemporánea,
pues lo compro mucho más que eso.
Pero no puedo, no puedo si no.
Muy bien.
Vamos a la siguiente, Nacho, que es el Barley.
No, el Brighton, perdón.
El Brighton.
Y aquí vamos a ir a una dota.
Yo creo que del Barley ya sé cuál has elegido.
Que lo sepas.
No sé, no sé, no sé.
Creo que sí.
Vamos a la de Brighton primero.
Años 80.
Vale.
Cuáles son los que más te gustan.
Cuéllito en pico, que es cierto que no es la cosa más chula del mundo, pero canta años
80.
Vale.
Las dos rayas verticales, mola mucho.
Inspiró esta a la mítica camiseta de la 2021, ¿te acuerdas del cuello de polo?
Que si no me equivoco es la primera camiseta que lleva la lana.
Y que es la camiseta más bonita que tiene el Brighton.
De hecho estaba entre esta y esa.
Y por quitar un cuello de polo y por hacerle un guiño a los 80.
La policía de Phoenixbury mola bastante.
Mola mucho más que la de Amex.
Mola.
Las cosas como son con todos los respuestos a American Express.
Sí, pero ya sabemos que a American Express cuando hay rayas las partes dos.
Sí, las partes.
Es que eso es lo que no me gusta de esta camiseta.
Esta camiseta respeta al patrón, luego el puño de la camiseta y el cuello muy chula.
El logo antiguo de Adidas.
Sí.
La de rojo y la van bien.
Queda muy chulo.
Bien, bien, bien.
Te la puedo aceptar.
Pero es que el Brighton creo que en su era moderna, en la Premier, ha tenido varias camisetas
bonitas.
Es que he pensado…
No tendría problema en meter la que se basó en esta como la camiseta más bonita.
Es que la tenía puesta.
La preciosa.
Yo realmente repase que 18 de las 20 camisetas tenían cuello de polo y dije…
Bien hecho.
Voy a darle alternancia a la gente.
Así no te vas a llevar 100 insultos sino 99.
Correcto.
De hecho hay gente que dirá hasta aquí era mi límite y gracias, Andrés, por respetarlo.
Muy bien, vamos a la del Barley.
No sé si será la que pensabas que ibas a coger o no.
Cuño, qué dicho.
Lo sabía perfectamente.
Es una camiseta.
Sabía que era esta.
Muy chula.
Que tiene el escudo del Barley a un lado y luego los leones del Barley en el otro con
esos detallitos amarillos.
El rollito terra mítica en el cuello.
Pero es que si te ha gustado la camiseta del Dila, esto te gusta.
Sí, los colores son los mismos.
Es muy mítica, por supuesto.
La publicidad de Enslick también es mítiquísima en el Barley.
La verdad es que está muy chula.
Es muy chula y queda muy bien los detalles en amarillo.
Hay una del Barley que a mí me hace mucha gracia que es esa que tiene franjas amarillas
como difuminadas amarillas, negras y blancas.
Sí, sé cuál es.
De tan fea que es me parece que es chula.
Pero te compro esta.
Está muy bien.
El cuello no es el que más me gusta, pero es muy chula.
Es el mismo cuello que el del Bournemouth, pero aquí no se nota un poco más disimulado.
Vamos a la siguiente que es la del Chelsea y esta la habéis visto durante todo el vídeo,
muchachos.
Ha estado aquí en el patrón.
Hombre.
Porque evidentemente hay otras camisetas que quizás gustan más, hay otras que quizás
gustan menos.
Pero es que esto es un camisetón tremendo.
Y teniendo en cuenta que la tenemos aquí además firmada por toda la plantilla del Chelsea,
no podíamos hacerla de menos.
Me gusta cómo queda la publicidad de Auto Glass.
Y me gusta algo que no es tan fácil de encajar en una camiseta del Chelsea que es una presencia
tan fuerte del blanco.
No es habitual que haya tanto blanco en una camiseta del Chelsea y aquí creo que le va
de maravilla.
Es el mejor ejemplo por el que digo cada temporada que no es tan difícil hacer camisetas bonitas
del Chelsea.
Tiene algo con hacer camisetas bonitas del Chelsea que parece que es un reto.
No hacer ni una.
Pero de hecho es que hasta la reedición que hicieron de esta, que no era terrible y posiblemente
sea de sus mejores camisetas estos últimos años, no acaba de ser lo mismo que la barbaridad
de camiseta que le hizo Humbro este año al Chelsea.
Que por cierto, hay una cosa que jamás entenderé, es el momento en el que Humbro decidió cambiar
de usar Humbro escrito a usar los dos rombos.
Igual que tampoco entenderé los años en los que Hadidas tenía Hadidas escrito así.
Y luego empezaron a usar el logo.
Algo que ojalá expliquen porque me cuesta entenderlo.
A lo mejor te enseñan las ventas y dicen mira, toma, toma explicación en números.
Puede ser.
Y le da un toque retro bastante guay.
Vamos a una, Nacho, que puede ser sorprendente y que de hecho usó otro equipo de Europa
con el mismísimo diseño dos años antes, que es el Crystal Palace, con la camiseta
local 97-98.
Si la gente piensa en una camiseta del Bayern con el patrocinio de Opel, es el mismísimo
diseño.
Exacto, el del mismo.
El mismo, solo que usado de la temporada 95-97, esta es usada de la 97-98, pero es la demostración
de que un template, si es bonito, siempre entra bien.
Bueno, está claro cuál es el estilo de camiseta ya te gusta y va a indignar a todo el mundo
por supuesto porque es un diseño de camiseta calcado a otros que ya se han llevado el premio
en este vídeo.
Pero no puedo negar que es una camiseta bonita.
Además con las franjas del Crystal Palace, perfecta.
No tengo problema con que esté marcado el escudo en ese marco blanco.
Me mola, ¿eh?
Creo que le va bien.
Me mola el cuello con las franjas blancas, rojas y azules.
Me gusta mucho.
Y te iré más.
Te irás más.
Siendo como somos españoles, creo que le debería servir de inspiración para que un
año el Barça le eche huevos y haga camiseta con cuello de polo blanco.
Una cosa parecida a esta.
Y vosotros diréis, el blanco está prohibido en la camiseta del Barça y tal.
Es cierto que normalmente no lleva blanco a la camiseta del Barça, pero últimamente,
del Barça hicieron aquella reedición de esa visitante tercera de cuando vistieron
de blanco con Cruyff.
No me gustó mucho esa camiseta.
No, pero a menos.
Pero han hecho hace poco, han sacado a la venta una camiseta retro, que es como bueno,
pues un homenaje tal, que sí tiene el cuello blanco.
Yo simplemente a los cules os animo a darle una vuelta.
Yendo esto, a mí me parece que una camiseta del Barça o un cuello de polo con el cuello
blanco sería espectacular.
Y que le metes los detalles blauguranas en el cuello, pues en vez de dejar la franja
esa blanca, le metes una franja roja y una franja.
Y la demostración es el Palace.
Esta camiseta es muy bonita.
Muy bonita y es insuperable en mi opinión.
Vamos a una que es diferente a las que hemos visto hasta el momento, Nacho.
Años 80, vamos a los Toffees, al Everton, con la camiseta local que llevaron entre
el 86 y el 89, que a muchos aficionados de Everton es la mejor camiseta de su historia
y que a mí me gusta mucho, aunque entiendo que puede despertar dudas por el hecho de
que el patrón de los cuadrados corte justo en las mangas y le echo las manguitas marcadas
en blanco.
Pero a mí me gusta mucho.
Bueno, no me dice mucho.
No me dice mucho.
El escudo antiguo es verdad que tiene su punto, pero el escudo del Everton actual siempre
me parece bonito.
No me parece un escudo ni que se pase de moderno ni que se pase de clásico, bien adaptado
a los tiempos.
A mí me entra como una de las mejores camisetas de los últimos años del Everton, la que
tiene cuello de polo con el patrón de Gunnison Park.
Muy chulo eso.
Por añadir también camisetas que sean más modernas, porque por ahora es todo añejo añejo.
Pero esa no tendría problema.
No hemos tenido ninguna del año 2000 para adelante.
Y estoy pensando así alguna del Everton que me gustara.
¿Hay alguna que otra visitante del Everton que también es bonita?
En los 2000, a inicios de los 2000, también tenían camisetas muy chulas.
Hay una que llevó arteta muy chula.
Pero bueno, no tengo problema de que esta es bonita.
Esta es muy bonita.
Pero no sé si es tanto como para la más bonita de la historia del club siendo un club como
el Everton.
A mí me gusta mucho.
He estado leyendo algún foro y mucha gente ponía, no esta, no esta, otra, tal.
Y hubo una que se acabó hace poco que la reedición, no digo que sea la más bonita,
pero la reedición me gustó de lo que llamaban las Black Watch, si no me equivoco, de cuando
vestían de negro con esa franja naranja.
Y esa estaba muy bonita.
Estuvo guapa.
Bueno, a gustos para gustos colores.
Vamos a entrar en la primera del siglo XX, ¿vale?
Año 2001-2002.
Apurando un poquito.
Que os pensabais que íbamos a acercarnos.
Que es la que llevó el Fulham local en la temporada 2001-2002 cuando tuvieron el mitiquérrimo
patrocinio de Pizza Hut que duró una temporada, pero nos dejó un camisetón icónico que
Si puede ser que tenga algún detalle que no guste a la gente, el hecho de que las franjas
dadidas no duren toda la manga, puede no gustar a la gente, pero a mí me mola que esté incluido
solo al fondo, que se limite al puño de la camiseta, que todo sea prácticamente blanco,
me gusta mucho.
Dos cosas sobre el Fulham.
Uno, al igual que el Everton, creo que su escudo aguanta muy bien el paso del tiempo.
Es un escudo que espero que no cambien nunca.
Era muy moderno ya hace 30 años.
Pero tiene el punto perfecto.
Es muy minimalista, sencillo, directo, va bien con el estilo sobrio que normalmente
tiene el club, va perfecto, es como muy reconocible.
El escudo del Fulham.
Dicho todo esto, me gusta lo de Pizza Hut y toda esta época, pero yo me quedo con la
de franjas rojas y negras.
Lo he pensado.
Que es la que han reditado hace poco.
A mí esa me parecía la mejor de largo.
Estaba entre esta y esa, pero esta me ha gustado.
Esta también es bonita, pero me quedo antes con la otra.
Es muy chula.
Fue el año que volvieron a la primera división después de 33 años de ausencia.
Duró Pizza Hut un año.
Casi nada.
Nos dejó un gran año.
Mítico, mítico.
Vamos a la del Leeds.
He estado muy, muy, muy tentado de poner una del año pasado.
La visitante amarilla.
Bueno, si te acuerdas.
Camiseta tremenda.
De las mejores de los últimos años.
Brutal, pero me ha acabado quedando con una que portó Río Ferdinand en la temporada 2001
que es muy sobria, muy sencillita, pero que creo que es muy bonita.
Que tiene los detalles azules y amarillos justo en el límite de la manga y en el cuello.
Las líneas esas blancas de Nike de inicios de los años 2000 alrededor de la camiseta.
Es cierto que no tiene muchísimos detalles, pero a mí me parece una camiseta muy chula.
Andrés, yo me la habría jugado directamente la del año pasado por poner una muy moderna.
Es que era otro cuello el cuello.
La del año pasado.
Habría sido un brólogo.
El año pasado.
Amarilla.
Con el escudo retro, que es un escudo que entiendan mucha gente y le parece muy feo.
A mí me encanta.
La publicidad de Red Bull que le iba perfecto.
Lo llamativa que era sin tampoco necesitar ser exagerada.
Perfecta.
Una camiseta muy bonita.
La del leech, que por cierto, te voy a decirte que en este caso yo creo que la has elegido
porque es una camiseta que en cuanto la ves dices leech.
Pero no sé si tanto por belleza.
Entiendo Strongbow y todo eso.
Creo que la has elegido porque piensas en el leech y piensas en el escudo.
Estaba entre este, la amarilla del año pasado y por no repetirme.
Pero le he hecho brólogo.
La del año pasado.
Preciosa.
Las cosas como son.
Sería posiblemente la segunda mejor de la historia del leech.
Hay una línea también que me gusta del leech que es la de las franjas verde oscuro y negro.
Hicieron una en su vuelta a la Premier que me gustó mucho basada ya en una versión antigua
que también está por ahí.
Y luego, fíjate aquí te voy a decir más.
Hay una que es amarilla.
Estoy tirando de memoria.
¿Años?
Pero es amarilla con el cuello azul y si no me equivoco, la publicidad es del Yorkshire
Post, si no me equivoco o algún medio local así, que esa camiseta es preciosa.
Sabe muy chula.
Preciosa.
Pero estoy tirando ya de memoria.
Estoy ya estirando de memoria.
¿Quién es la siguiente?
La mejor camiseta de la historia de la Premier League, a menos la que más me gusta a mí,
esto es una cuestión completamente subjetiva, que es la de Liverpool local de la 93 a 95
que es maravillosa.
Es una maravilla el patrocinio que no entra en contacto definitivamente con ese patrón
de abajo, el escudo en el centro también así más con detalles más rojos, pero también
con los detalles verdes de las mangas y del cuello.
Es perfecta.
Lo único que me podría chirrear es que Adidas esté por encima de Liverpool.
Ni siquiera eso.
Pero no me molesta.
Ese Adidas que colocaban en esa zona como justo inmediatamente más baja del cuello.
A ver, tengo que decir que los tiempos cambian, esta camiseta tiene pinta de ser incómoda
a llevar.
Yo la he llevado porque tengo esta camiseta en casa, en verano no es recomendable.
Pero dicho esto, a mí esas franjas que entraban de esa manera tan agresiva en la camiseta,
el escudo que además parece estar como cosido a mano, el sponsor de Kalsberg, todo en la
camiseta me encanta.
Es una camiseta preciosa.
Y me gustaba mucho esa... que además lo va recuperando poco a poco Adidas, esa tendencia
a meter esas franjas tan gordas en la camiseta siempre me gustó.
Y ese color rojo que parece un poco piruleta también tenía su punto.
Aunque en Liverpool me gusta cuando viste el rojo también un poco más oscuro, me encanta
esta camiseta.
Hay gente que podría decir, es que los 90 Liverpool tenían camisetas muy bonitas porque
verde y blanca, la de los dos cuadrados que también es espectacular.
La que ya canto sabe candy.
Esta misma, he estado pensando en esta pero para mí esta es la que más me gusta y por
tanto me tenía que quedar con ella.
Añado también que a mí siempre me ha encantado esa de color como marfil, no es blanco, es
un blanco más... hace ya bastantes años que tenía el cuello así redondo y con detalles
rojos, esa siempre me ha parecido de las más bonitas.
Muy bonita.
Vamos a continuar con los años 90.
No hay manera de salir de aquí.
Es que es la mejor época de las camisetas y eso que no la viví porque ya sabéis que
yo nací en los 90 pero al final Nacho las vivió un poquito más.
Yo a mitad justo.
Tú a mitad justo en el momento en el que el Manchester City portó esta camiseta como
tercera equipación, la mítica camiseta que llevó Liam Gallagher en aquel mítico
photoshoot.
Fucking biblical.
Con este blanco, el patrocinio de Brother.
Always has vibes in the area.
Las franjas verticales.
Que personajes.
Nada, muy bonitas.
Estaba entre esta y la local de Brother, no la que tiene ahí sino la de dos años después.
Es que a ver si se le hicieron la promo con la público de Brother y saliendo ellos dos
que les hicieron la promo.
Es que es tremenda.
Muy bonita esta camiseta, muy bonita.
Me gustaría que la volvieran a intentar reeditar, lo que pasa es que tengo un miedo con Puma
ahí y lo que se lo puede ocurrir en los próximos años.
Puma siempre siento que quiere reeditar cosas pero luego quiere darle el girito para que
no sea una reedición tal cual.
Y ese girito es el que nunca me gusta.
Aunque sí te diré que la reedición que hicieron el año pasado de aquella camiseta
visitante, la verde y amarilla, esa estuvo muy bien.
Estuvo muy bien.
También es cierto que era una copia idéntica de la que habían llevado a finales de los
90.
Pero esa estuvo muy bien hecha así que ojalá reediten también esta.
Vamos al otro equipo de Manchester.
Vamos al otro equipo de Manchester Nacho.
La época, la temporada más gloriosa de su historia que acabó con el triplete.
Es cierto que no llevaron esa camiseta en la final.
Había muchas opciones, tanto locales como visitantes de finales de los 90 y inicios
de los 2000.
Pero aunque parezca incómodo de llevar, vamos a verla Jesús, la cremallera en el cuello
es que lo de humbro en las mangas, es que en manga larga esta camiseta tenía que dar
un calor.
Y es tan bonita, con el puño al final, el blanco, el rojo y el negro, es que es espectacular.
Me compro todo pero lo de la cremallera me asesina.
Me asesina, no la puedo decir que es la más bonita.
Para mí, creo que el Manchester United en el triplete de 2009 lleva una camiseta preciosa,
por acercarnos un poco más a nuestra época, lleva una camiseta preciosa, la ves y piensas
en Rooney que está enhorrando.
Boafona además de patrocinio.
No, no, no.
¿No era Boafona?
Yo estoy pensando en otra.
No, era justo después de Boafona.
¿Quién era ese patrocinador?
¿A, IG?
Igual sí, espérate.
¿Puede ser IG?
Estamos hablando de 2009, ¿no?
No, no es un segundo.
2009, IG.
Amigos.
¿Esta, no?
Esta, esta que tenía por detrás, parece un poco simple, lo sé.
No, pero está muy chula.
Pero tenía además como la franja vertical blanca por detrás, a mí esa me encantaba.
Estaba pensando en esta.
Y tengo que decir que también una que me encanta es la azul con esa especie de tréboles
que llevaron en su día, que siempre que lo veo pienso en Geeks.
Esa me parece la Bruce Banana del Manchester United.
Está muy chula también.
Y a lo mejor me quedo con esa, porque es una camiseta realmente especial y diferente.
Quizás solo Bruce Banana ha conseguido capturar un template tan especial como ese.
Puede ser.
Sobre todo porque cuando haces esas cosas os sale muy bien, os sale muy mal y hay pocos
cosas en las que ha salido muy bien.
Vamos a continuar con la del Newcastle, que podría ser esta misma que lleva Nacho puesta
en el vídeo, pero a mí personalmente me gusta más esta del cuellito redondo cerrado.
Estoy contigo.
A mí esta me parece la más bonita de la historia del Newcastle.
Sí, yo pensaba que te ibas a quedar con esta.
A mí el cuello de esa me gusta más que esta y me gusta además el orden de los elementos.
Haridas encima, luego el Newcastle, luego el Newcastle Brown Ale.
En general, como está todo, te diré que incluso que tiene una cosa rara a la camiseta
y es que las franjas de aidas de los brazos tienen un reborde amarillo.
A lo mejor habría mejorado incluso sin ese reborde, pero luego lo ves y dices mira,
pues también le queda.
Va en consonancia con el amarillo del Newcastle Brown Ale y luego también con el amarillo
del propio Adidas.
Es precioso.
Me parece una camiseta espectacular.
Estaba evidentemente entre esta y entre la que llevaron justo después de esta, que
es la del cuello de polo, pero a mí esta me gusta más que la del cuello de polo porque
debo reconocer que no soy muy fan del acabado azul con el negro de Adidas de esos años,
como sí tiene esta camiseta en las franjas.
Y por supuesto también estaba la de las franjas horizontales.
Me ha gustado que las franjas horizontales no son muy habituales en el fútbol, las franjas
granetes y azules le iban muy bien a la camiseta.
Esta es la que reeditaron hace dos años.
La han reeditado dos veces, una con puma, otra con Adidas.
La de Adidas era bonita, la de Pumas me parecía casi perfecta.
¿Ah sí?
Casi perfecta.
¿Entonces la recuerdo yo mal?
Lo único que tenía eran unas letras así como en chino que las destrozaban un poco,
pero aquella me pareció de las invasiones más bonitas que ha tenido el Newcastle con
Benitez el año de Rondón.
Sí, muy chula.
Bueno, vamos a la camiseta más moderna de todo el vídeo, que de hecho es una camiseta
de este año, que es la mejor camiseta de la Premier League esta temporada, que no es
otra que la del Nottingham Forest de esta temporada.
¿Vale?
He estado buscando...
La más bonita.
A mí me parece la más bonita.
Es cierto que la reedición de esta es también muy bonita, podemos ver la siguiente imagen,
Jesús, para verlo, pero a mí me gusta personalmente más la de este año porque tiene más detalles
y porque además las dos estrellas de la Champions están incluidas en el escudo, que me parece
un detalle top.
Y que además hay gente que se la pudo comprar sin publicidad, que eso está muy guay también.
Qué difícil, porque la otra es tan simple que le da ese toque de sin complicaciones.
¿Sabes?
Sí, sí, somos las dos muy bonitas, a mí me gusta personalmente más la de este año.
O sea, la otra tiene más elementos que modernizan o dinamizan el diseño, pues que sí, luego
los hombros...
Y luego tiene una franjita negra, si os fijáis, o una franjita roja más oscuro dentro de
las propias franjas rojas.
Jesús, ¿con cuál te quedas?
Con esta, ¿no?
Vamos, vamos.
Es muy bonita esta, es que luego puesta además es...
Pues que queda tremenda, ¿eh?
Muy bonita.
Lo único que no me gusta, como pequeña queja paradidas, yo entiendo que las camisetas
que hacen para futbolistas tienen que quedarles bien a los futbolistas y no molestarles.
Ya que vais a hacer cosas para gente, para los aficionados, y hacéislas auténticas y
tal, las de réplica de venta que sean un poquito más oversized, que tengan un poquito
un poco más, que no queden entalladas al milímetro a cada persona, que queden un poquito más,
que es la gracia de las camisetas.
Si al menos si vas a hacer una camiseta con un toque retro, si no va a ser con un toque
retro, pues no, pero si va a ser con un toque retro, pues que quede algo más oversized.
Y enseñadores, ni puñetero caso, nos gustan las camisetas...
Talladitas.
Petaditas.
Bueno, vamos a entrar a las últimas, ¿vale?
Y podría haber ido con la visitante que llevó el Sanderla en el año pasado.
Bueno, tanto como la más bonita.
Pero me voy a quedar con la original.
Me voy a quedar con la original, utilizada entre 91 y 94.
Me parece espectacular.
Es preciosa esta camiseta.
Además el patrocinio de Vaux queda tremendamente bien.
Preciosa.
Porque claro, la del año pasado es como una reedición más moderna y algo más difuminada,
pero así que todo tan enmarcado queda muy guay.
Chulísima esta camiseta.
Una cosa que sí le compro a Hummel de la del año pasado es que en la edición de manga
larga el diseño de las mangas llega hasta el final.
En la de este año se corta y continúa en blanco, al menos las fotos que he podido encontrar
de la camiseta en muchas ocasiones con muchos jugadores distintos.
Es que pensaba eso, pero haces zoom y continúa.
O la lleva muy pegada o no lo sé.
Bueno, esta es preciosa.
Pero en manga corta es espectacular.
Y es más bonita que la reedición, que es una reedición bastante fiel, pero esta es
chulísima.
Esta es muy chula y está muy bien.
Vamos a continuar con los años 90.
Ya sabéis que aquí 90's keep para siempre.
Con el Tottenham y la camiseta que llevo local en la 96-97.
Es una camiseta sencillita.
Es una camiseta sencillita, pero me parece que los detalles, sobre todo en manga larga,
con el puño azul, el escudo del Tottenham enmarcado, que a mí me parece que queda guay.
Y sobre todo el cuello abotonado, que por mucho que sea cuello de polo, si no es abotonado
es una basura, creo que está muy bien.
A ver, es camiseta de ir a una boda.
Si, te pones un jersey por encima y no se nota.
Es pura elegancia, como muchas veces es la equipación del Tottenham.
Te tengo que contar que este verano estuve en Boston y entramos, mi novia y yo, en una
tienda de ropa vintage, ropa retro, segunda mano y tal.
Y veo que en un maniquí tienen puesta una camiseta del Tottenham Hotspur de Pony y talla
ML, una cosa así.
Una talla para que se me entienda que se podría poner la gran parte, la mayoría de la gente.
Y le digo a mi novia, estoy seguro que estando donde estamos, en Boston y en una tienda de
segunda mano, esta gente no sabe cuánto vale esta camiseta.
Miro el precio, vaya por delante, que era una camiseta visitante, azul oscuro, con tonos
así un poco blancos por aquí y tal, 70 dólares.
Solo.
Estaba pero cuidadísima, no tenía ni un solo efecto.
Y cuando veo los 70 dólares digo, mira, no la compro por un tema de no gastar algo que
antes de entrar a esta tienda no necesitaba.
Pero esta camiseta la puedes comprar y aunque no la quieras, luego la vendes a Classic Football
Shirts y ellos la venden por 160 euros.
O más, o más incluso.
Lo que me alucinó lo de verlo y decir, no tenéis ni idea, no era una camiseta de 3000
euros, pero era esto de decir, no sabéis por cuánto lo estoy poniendo, está por debajo
el precio del mercado.
70 dólares que son como 55-60 euros, no es tanto.
No sé si era eso o al cambio eran 70 euros, pero me pongas o me pongas, si eran 70 dólares
o euros no era lo que valía.
Y me quedé mirándola diciendo, no lo saben, no se han metido en Classic Football Shirts.
Es que además Classic Football Shirts últimamente se ha subido a la parra de una forma impresionante.
Una camiseta que valdría muchísimo dinero en Classic Football Shirts y que puede que
ya lo había valido si ha estado en la página web es la del West Ham y he escogido una visitante.
Tienen locales muy bonitas, muy bonitas, pero yo me he quedado con una visitante que llevaron
en la 2002-2003, año en que tristemente descendieron, pero que las franjas, el cuello quizá no
es lo más tal, pero el patrocinio de Dr. Martens, el parche ese antiguo de la Premier,
que evidentemente éste lo tenían todas las camisetas, pero todo hace a que esta camiseta
sea muy bonita.
Sí, me gusta, me gusta.
Lo que pasa es que ya sabes que yo con el West Ham me quedo normalmente con aquella que
hicieron del Thames Ironworks.
La llevaron en un partido porque luego les prohibieron llevarlo en más, así es el West
Ham United, muy West Ham, pero a mí aquella me pareció perfecta.
No me lo dejaron llevar porque el parche era demasiado grande, el escudo, pero aquel escudo
con la insignia de los mineros, la bandera del Reino Unido, todo de negro, la publicidad
también de negro, pero te acepto esto.
Me gusta mucho de alternativas, no estamos diciendo que el West Ham no tenga camisetas
bonitas locales, tiene muchas, pero de alternativas me gustaba la que hicieron hace dos años,
que era toda blanca, con el patrocinio de Bedwyr también en blanco y creo que le daba
un toque muy chulo.
Por acabar, misma temporada, 2002-2003, para que luego os quejéis de que no hay camisetas
del siglo XXI, el año en que los Wolves ascienden a la Premier League con Doritos como patrocinador
de la camiseta.
Es cierto que la camiseta en manga corta no tiene el puño acabado de esa forma, pero
está muy guapa.
Y el patrocinio de Doritos es una chulada.
Camiseta de puro cachondeo.
Es una chulada.
Espectacular, espectacular.
Espectacular, a tope con ella, a tope con ella, me encanta.
Es que es increíble.
¿Quién te patrocina?
Doritos.
Sí, ya está.
Espectacular.
Porque Pizza Hut ya está guapo.
Y además de igual, porque como vas de naranja, luego lo otro es como medio rojo, medio amarillo,
el logo de Doritos y demás, el resto de la camiseta no necesita nada.
Doritos.
Está muy bien.
Impresionante esta camiseta, ¿eh?
Es que es tremenda.
De auténtico culto.
Es tremenda.
No sé si es la más bonita, pero para mí es la mejor camiseta de los Wolves en toda
su historia.
Me encanta.
¿Cuál es la que más te ha gustado de todas?
La del Newcastle United.
¿Sí, no?
Hombre, no, tú verás.
A mí la de Liverpool sigue siendo la favorita.
Y la de los Wolves.
Y la de los Wolves también está muy chula con Doritos.
Me ha recordado la del Sheffield Wednesday con Chupa Chups.
Tremendo también eso.
Jesús da la de Liverpool como ganadora.
¿Cuál es para ti la ganadora?
Me parece la del Forrest, ¿no?
Te gusta mucho la del Forrest, ¿no?
Sí, pero bueno.
Bueno.
La tienes sin publicidad, ¿no?
Qué suerte, qué cabrón.
Y fue por suerte porque me la vendieron.
O sea, al principio lo vendieron con el anterior patrocinador.
¿Qué es cierto?
Ah, vale, vale.
No sé, no sabía que estaba insinuando.
Un segundo pensaba que me la vendieron.
Alerta Interpol.
Lo pidí justo en eso, en el impasse de los dos patrocinadores.
Porque enseguida pusieron en los dos y hasta ahí no la vendían.
Sí, Bailies.
Qué zorro.
Jesús Sánchez.
Bueno, amigos, pues nada, hasta aquí nuestro video sobre las...
Camisetas más bonitas del fútbol inglés.
Una por cada club.
Como veis, esta es mi ganadora.
La de Andrés es la del Liverpool.
Con el puesto de honor para la de los Walls y Doritos.
Sí, que nos deje la gente en comentarios si quieren que hagamos ese video de las camisetas
de la Football League.
Hostia.
Que...
No sé, si la gente le apetece la que comentaste tú en el vídeo aquel de alternativas.
Sí, 72 camisetas.
Todo por saco.
72.
Y ya está, no.
Pero con las cinco mejores, una cosa por el estilo.
Y ya está.
Pues nada, amigos.
Muchas gracias por estar al otro lado y decidnos cuál es la que más os ha gustado a vosotros
de todas las que hemos escogido y también, pues, en general.
Y si vais con camisetas por la calle o veis desnudos...
O del Wigan o del West Brom.
Hay a cada uno.
O del Sheffield United.
Si tú vas a comprar el pan en bolas o en Albornoz, pues libre eres.
Otra cosa que tengan por la calle, pero yo no sé quién pone las leyes.
¡Vamos!